and she said you're crazy you're crazy
because i told her listen there's a real
gap we can be a bridge between
everybody who wants to engage with the
israeli ecosystem nobody has this kind
of access nobody understands the
ecosystem like an industry insider
somebody who grew up here who knows all
the founders because they went with them
to the military and they went to school
and they went to the technion and they
went through so many similar experiences
we can really be that bridge and we can
be the eyes and ears on the ground of
everyone who wants to come in
and she's like you're crazy
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today we are joined by mol asia
founding partner and co-ceo of angels
and general partner in the ingenuity
fund
an israeli high-tech insider a graduate
of the idf's elite intelligence unit
8200 more leads iangel's investment
committee deal screening due diligence
and portfolio management activities
moore's tech background with sap ibm and
amdocs has proven invaluable in
assessing new technologies and her
ability to deep dive with entrepreneurs
into their business strategy and
solution has created a strong foundation
for relationship building
moore has been instrumental in
structuring and pricing investment
rounds and consistently brings value-add
partnerships to help portfolio companies
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm good thank you for having me
thank you so much for being here
i love your work i've been following
your work for a long time with i angels
but also before that uh with sap and ibm
and um docs
mba colombia and bachelors in
mathematics and computer science and
with a technion
amazing track record you're either on
the board of directors or a board
observer of some of the most amazing
companies that i've been following
closely in the israel ecosystem and so
we have a lot of amazing things to talk
about uh but but just as much as i want
to talk about angels and and the
investments that you're doing there and
congratulations on on the recent raise
of the new fund
i want to also dive into your own
journey and understand you better and
gain a little inspiration from the
decisions that you've made along your
career following your passion and what
has led you to where you are today so mo
maybe we can get started going all the
way back even you know to when you were
in 8200 and what really drop drove you
throughout your career as you're
navigating through the different
milestones
yeah
i think i mean the first kind of
conscious decision that i remember
making into you know diving into the
space was um was in 11th grade i don't
know if people know this but in israel
when you're in high school you already
choose a major you already choose kind
of like what you want to specialize in
while still in high school
and in 10th grade you do everything
you're a generalist and then 11th grade
you need to kind of choose a domain and
i remember i was doing elimination i was
like i'm doing elimination based on what
like the the teachers i didn't like so
much or what i didn't find like too easy
or i couldn't get a straight a without
like you know putting a lot of effort so
i eliminated and eliminated and
eliminated and chose physics and
computer science
and like the top math and i was native
english speaker so those are kind of
like the four core
uh subjects that i was uh focusing on
and uh and and and it it's kind of funny
to think that through that elimination
process where i really wanted to choose
the the things that i felt i was the
strongest ad because i was it was easy
to me
these are the kind of choices that were
very important for down the road because
because because you choose computer
science and you choose physics then you
know all all of a sudden the people who
do this are recognized and uh are
scouted by the top units in the military
because they want to bank on kind of
your experience and everything that
you've gained in high school and so i i
i mean i think this has definitely been
helpful
in kind of uh being on the radar of
8200. now 8200 is you know needless to
say and you really only appreciate it
much much much later in life
uh was one of the best experiences and i
think one of the you know most
interesting roles that women have in the
military at least
um
so i had a technological role in 8200 an
opportunity to see some of you know
unique uh technologies uh working with
people
uh who are specialists in encryption in
algorithms in data science um
and in in how our intelligence is really
being made
and
i had a great great experience there and
also had an opportunity to learn from
from from different people around me
i think this was very
much an experience that kind of
you know
grounds you or helps you
uh become a better leader and uh
afterwards i kind of you know i wanted
to pursue
i want to kind of take all my experience
and continue on that same track
and i remember when i told folks that i
was that that i was uh accepted to the
technion i'm going to study mathematics
and computer science they're like oh you
know everybody who who do who has done
your route is kind of like the the
classic way to go
um
so so i did that for three years and i
have to say it's a very very intense
program you kind of you know first year
you kind of you just want to make it you
just want to like just want to make that
first year and get through that first
year
um and then in the second year like oh
my god what have i done i'm never gonna
get this through
uh through this it's it's crazy and the
you know the professors are writing on
the board and it's already
you know a combination of latin and math
and and algorithms and like everything
is a big mess uh and then by the third
year just okay i have to i have to
finish i have to pedal through
and uh and finish the best way i can
with best possible outcome uh and that's
what i did so uh
um i think it also kind of taught me a
lot about
about you know pedaling through and how
much you can endure how much you can
um
how much you know you can really uh work
through in in in situations where
everything is like so stressed so much
work you've been you know we've been to
similar programs like very uh very uh uh
kind of high-paced programs so
it's definitely one of those
when you reflect back at those
experiences when you think through you
know those really difficult times and i
can really picture you know sitting in
the technion and you're studying
mathematics and computer science middle
of the night like 2 am
what
what what what gets you through it so
obviously now looking back in
perspective you see that you see what it
allowed you and you you see that you
know choosing the right courses in high
school in the right sort of major in
high school has led you also to the path
of 8200 but but in that moment when
you're in the middle of the trenches and
all the difficulty you have a lot of
people around you that chose different
paths right that didn't choose to go and
work in the middle of the night and
algorithms what gets you through then
those difficult nights
i'll tell you first i mean the first
year is is very very difficult the drop
rate for my program the first year is
over 50
so over 50 percent of the people who
start the program
start the the you know the degree
don't make it through the first year
and all these people they leave and they
do something completely different
they're so be i feel like they're so
beaten some of them went to become
lawyers like something completely
completely different from what the kind
of trade training or kind of education
that we were going through so
the fact that you're there in the second
year and you all of a sudden you see
around you or like just barely half the
people uh you're like you know there's a
reason i'm here
and i'm not gonna toss out and throw out
the window
everything that brought me to this day
you're sitting and and also the reason
like you're sitting in the lab
and you're you're working on this
project
and you're it's really intense you're
kind of into the code and you're trying
to figure something out and you're
looking at the clock and like oh my god
like another three hours have gone by
it's like 2 am already we're not done
um so i guess the people who stayed
really became the glue of one another
help people kind of you know make it
through and there's also a lot of
brainstorming a lot of things that you
see today in organizations you know that
are all open space and everything is
cubicle and people are kind of asking
questions and trying to help one another
that was very much the the feel
um and i think that it's um
almost feels like a team effort like
it's very very difficult to be kind of
alone and do it by yourself and
um
it's uh you can go to a dark place
though it's very fun to have people
around you who understand and and like
people there you take the top people
who've always have been successful in
life and in school and you you take them
to a place where
you know there's they're used to being
really good at what they do and you look
at the board on all the grades and
people get like a single digit grade
people who've gotten straight a's their
entire lives they've got
you're looking down and there's somebody
who got an eight
on the exam and somebody got like a
thirteen
i remember the the first day in my
university where the dean is stood in
front of everybody and he said something
that resonates with men until today and
really is is amazing to think about he
said you know all of you are used to
being the valedictorians on the topic of
your class
you know inevitably half of you are
gonna be below average
one of you is one of you is gonna be the
lowest in the class and this is and and
it was mind-boggling and i was watching
how everybody you know their faces turn
red and
and now it's only a question of where am
i going to be and and it's really it's
really amazing now mo it's such an
amazing journey beyond uh beyond just
those years that we talked about where
i'm i can oversee how you're taking this
resilience and this passion with you
wherever you go talk to me about the
founding of i angels something that is
so predominant today in the israeli
ecosystem
what led you to to think of of creating
this vc fund
okay so i mean i i was
always working in corporate okay so i
started my career software engineer was
working for sap led development teams
there
again you know had an experience in new
york which i think kind of connected all
the dots you all of a sudden realize
that
you are in the hot this hub of business
and people really want to engage with
what's going on in israel but they
almost feel like outsiders they don't
really know who to trust where to go how
to navigate people who are used to be
being very active and managing their own
investments in the us then they kind of
feel like they should be doing the same
thing in a different
region
they're they're really uh seeing this is
a major major challenge now i met shelly
my partner when i was in new york so i
was doing my mba there and there and
afterwards working for ibm and she was
working uh
for a hedge fund called avenue capital
and we became instant friends she came
back to israel and worked for goldman i
came back to israel afterwards worked
for amdocs and when i was actually
pregnant with my second child i have
five kids so when i was pregnant with my
second child i told her listen i have
this idea this is what i'm gonna do and
i think that you should do this with me
and she said you're crazy you're crazy
because i told her listen there's a real
gap we can be a bridge between
everybody who wants to engage with the
israeli ecosystem nobody has this kind
of access nobody understands the
ecosystem like an industry insider
somebody who grew up here who knows all
the founders because they went with them
to the military and they went to school
and they went to the technion and they
went through so many similar experiences
we can really be that bridge and we can
be the eyes and ears on the ground of
everyone who wants to come in
and she's like you're crazy
and maybe i was because both of us had
like really really a great thing going
we had a great job um
and we loved what we did and we were
very much
quirby like we loved having the kind of
backing of a big organization you can do
so many things you can do m a's and you
can you know you're working closely with
management some of the you know really
top companies of the world
and um and it took her a few months to
actually for me to be able to convince
her that this uh that this makes sense
and we became essentially
entrepreneurs we founded this business
like a startup company this is a product
company we have our own product in r d
and at the same time we're creating
on one hand like a marketplace we want
to bring on members and people into our
vc platform and on the other hand create
a state-of-the-art
institutional grade offering where we
originate and do d and do due diligence
and everything on these opportunities
and uh and enable
kind of
very high quality group investing at the
end of the day we wanted to enable each
investor
whether it's
institutional stem institutional family
office or individual
to be your own vc this is what we wanted
to do for ourselves this was like a
challenge that we recognize as young
professionals this is what we want to do
we want to start investing just like you
do right you michael you started
investing you already know kind of
what's your strategy what you like what
you don't like
we were like that so we kind of wanted
to create um a platform or a product
that answers that need for ourselves
we're like who does angel investing like
you know in the old age you don't even
know what's going on with the companies
you put like 50 000 there 50 000 there
there you have no visibility into what's
going on with companies and no ability
to be successful unless you follow on
and
you know and and have these rights many
times you don't have these rights so
that was the key motivation we wanted to
bring it to the next generation wanted
to do it much much better more efficient
more transparent in a way where you know
you have a dashboard you see all your
investments like a bank like you want to
see
you want to see uh um what your
portfolio is worth are you building you
want somebody to talk to if you want to
navigate that portfolio so that was the
motivation
and it was very you know it was baby
steps it was really like founding a
startup so everything that our uh
companies go through we've been there
and i think that's really also part of
the magic
um no and you know eight years later
you'll tell me a second as you're
focusing on angels i also want to really
get clear you know you're developing
this you know you're developing your own
expertise you're developing the ability
to then
translate that expertise to allow others
to make their own decisions you're
focusing on specific trends within the
israeli ecosystem what what are those
and why those specifically
yeah
well first i mean i think it's uh
somebody who's been following the
israeli ecosystem for many years
you can really recognize cycles in
innovation around specific sectors some
you know there are times where you know
there was a time where i saw i want to
say 50 companies
uh that are developing technologies for
the automotive space maybe 50. wow and
we ended up investing in one we ended up
investing in arbeit robotics which is an
amazing company that announced that it's
uh spack on nasdaq
um
uh in mo in in march and they're uh
going to be
uh going to be merging into us back at a
valuation of 723 million which is wow
amazing we led their kind of
post seed round
but we saw maybe 50 of those and a
similar thing happened with agritech
there was a point in time where we saw
dozens dozens of companies so sometimes
we
understand and we like to do it kind of
like before it's already a trend kind of
do analysis and we do research and we
look at new things that are happening in
the ecosystem and we map it out and then
we are we're developing a thesis around
that specific sector so if it was around
agritech or if it was around drone
technology that was also like a big big
uh
trend
uh automotive
uh uh enterprise software and uh and
cyber was something that we're kind of
bringing from home and you know have a
lot of experience in uh and and also you
know digital health and uh food tech
foodtech was never a sector with within
its own
it's something that really became a
sector in the last couple of years now
uh uh in angels we've been you know
following and investing in digital
health
seven years ago
so now you know with corona uh
a lot of companies have been enjoying
these tailwinds and growing considerably
we feel like we've been there very very
early on same thing with blockchain
technologies we've been investing in
them creating portfolio and blockchain
technologies since 2017.
amazing so much you know uh much much
before
the big boom the winter and everything
else so we really try to recognize it
kind of really before it happens develop
a thesis around a specific sector and
then um and you know make the investment
in the the companies that we feel can
have a real opportunity to be a category
leader and have to be uh positioned well
on the global setting um so everything
needs to be
things that have
uh uh
very
you know big big ideas or big problems
we generally like to invest in in
companies that can that at least have
the opportunity to be a billion dollar
company or to really make make a change
in the world really be a category leader
and of course you know from now then
anything can happen anything can happen
um but we want to we want to back the
companies that
believe that they have a chance at
making it
really big
i love it i love it and you know there's
so much more that i want to talk about i
can't believe i every time i get so
angry at myself that i call this show 20
minute leaders and not 30 minute leaders
but
but there's you know you've had some
some really incredible announcements so
just in a couple of sentences tell me a
little bit about where where you're at
today with the angels and then i have i
have three short questions that i want
to ask you
okay
well i'm just today we we just recently
announced formally um our new fund
angels ventures one is that the new
institutional fund that we collaborated
with uh the european investment fund so
european investment fund is one of the
top uh institutional investors in the
world they manage money for the european
union the european bank and the long
list of institutions in europe um and we
kind of uh share
uh share a similar viewpoint with this
fund to invest early stage uh
and uh and invest in you know the
technologies of the future and the teams
are building our future so this is what
we're focusing on and essentially uh
very complementary to our vc platform
and uh you know we have uh also plans
for the next uh you know next uh
offerings or next products like a growth
fund and an additional uh
early stage fund so
we're kind of like really building it
because we see our companies mature and
we want to be able to
uh not only support our portfolio
company but all companies but also come
in where it makes sense uh and there's a
gap in the market and the b and c round
so this is definitely something that
we're considering as
we grow further
and um
yeah it's very exciting times
it's also exciting to be an entrepreneur
these days i think it's a it's a great
time
100 i recently read an interesting post
on linkedin of somebody who asked is it
a better time to be an entrepreneur to
be an investor and which is it and it's
a great sign that this is the question
that is being asked because it's all
around it's it's a great time to be in
tech and to be
and to be involved in these great
innovations that are taking place
everything is back you can't separate
tech from the world everything is tech
everything you touch real estate is tech
anything everything is tech
so um it's definitely eating the world
and i think it's
um it's uh again
i don't know i don't know how to answer
the question if it's better to be an
entrepreneur an investor
a good one
it's a good one well take me back to
your childhood what really what sparked
your curiosity as a kid
well i think uh again something that i
recognized today and maybe kind of my
husband really appreciates
today i grew up with with two brothers
so at home it was always you know gaming
sci-fi movies futuristic
movies
these are these are the kind of things
that made me i feel
kind of look at the future of what i
think the future might look like
what
what are people gonna do what kind of
robotic systems are we gonna have what
planets are we gonna man i don't know
it's something that you know i really
loved as a kid
um
and was part of my upbringing for sure
and i think it it it
shapes what i'm saying i still really
enjoy it so it's uh i'm a total sci-fi
geek
and uh
and i think it uh
i'm i'm shocked that some of the movies
that it kind of you know that i enjoyed
growing up in terms of the technology
were not there yet
it's mind-boggling to me
what inspires us today
today i mean it's similar to the things
that i mentioned i love being i love
being around people that have these
really big dreams
and they know they have the conviction
that this is what's going to happen
and sometimes i sit in a room and
and somebody shares their vision
on on the company and i'm like
you know wow if we hit half of that
that'd be amazing
and then you know and then we start
working together in the following year
i'm like i'm almost i don't know if i'm
surprised or not surprised that we've
made such a big impact or such a big
jump um and i think you know as uh
richard branson said it once if you're
if your dreams don't scare you they're
too small
so this is the kind of you know
environment that we
that we cultivate in our company and the
kind of dna that we look for in
entrepreneurs and at the end of the day
we want to have fun
it's a long journey uh can be very
challenging at times
and so we're looking for people who
share that passion
and uh
definitely part of the inspiration of
getting up in the morning and you know
and taking meetings and going to work
i love it and what are three words to
describe yourself
i'm gonna use words and maybe other
people describe me maybe it's gonna be
slightly better
um i think one thing
i i feel i am and i guess other people
uh repeat is the problem solver
um
very very early in my career i had an
amazing manager that every time people
would come to him with problems he said
don't come to me with problems come to
me with solutions
so i i practice that all the time and i
feel that the second word i'm gonna say
is creative
so it's not only about solving a problem
but it's sometimes
when you're work when you're um give
delta hand
and it's just not good enough
then how do you change the hand that
you're dealt how you bring new
um new variables into this problem and
and that maybe other people didn't think
about and change and be able to change
the outcome around that so creative
um
a third one
maybe
funny people say i'm funny
i i think i have a geeky kind of
man honey
i love it and no i really want to thank
you for for the time that you gave to
this and how busy you are and and i
think that the work that you're doing
both your perspective on the ecosystem
and and your own personal journey is
inspiring but i love the energy and i'm
living here with with much more energy
than i started and and i really thank
you for that and thank you for the great
work they're doing with angels best of
luck with it with the new institutional
fund and i can't wait to see to see it
become an even more important and
critical part of our ecosystem and
thank you stay safe and stay healthy
thank you you too we'll take everything
else offline we'll do another 20 minutes
thank you